in this video we're going to talk about
a concept in chemistry that's quite
important known as dilutions
so let's do an example so
let's say we have a large vat as much as
we need it's a one molar solution of
sodium sulfate and it's an aqueous
solution so sodium sulfate is dissolved
in water and let's say we also have as
much water as we need and what we want
to do is create a solution another
aqueous solution of sodium sulfate but
one that has a different concentration
in this case one that has a lower
concentration so we want to create a
0.125
molar solution of sodium sulfate and we
want 500 milliliters of this new
solution
pause this video and think about how you
would approach that
all right now let's think about this
together so first let's just go over the
intuition you have a higher
concentration here you have a lower
concentration here so our intuition
would tell us is that we're going to
take less than 500 milliliters of our
original solution pour some of that in
that's going to have a sufficient number
of moles of sodium sulfate that if we
were to then fill this up to 500
milliliters that we would then have a
0.125
molar solution so the question really is
is how much of this do we have to put in
which we can then dilute with water to
get to our goal solution
well to answer that question we just
have to figure out how many moles of
sodium sulfate need to be in this final
goal solution this one or this one
depending on how we visualize it and
then how much of our original solution
of our one molar solution do we need to
take out to have that many moles
and to think about how many moles we
just have to remind ourselves what
molarity is we know already that
molarity
is equal to number of moles
number of moles
of
solute
per
liters of solution
liters of solution
or another way to think about it is if
we multiply both sides by liters of
solution we would get liters
of solution
times
molarity
times molarity
is equal to the number of moles of
solute number
of moles
of solute
so what we can do is say all right how
many moles of our solute do we need in
our goal well to do that we just have to
say all right we want to eventually have
500 milliliters of solution
or we could rewrite that as 0.500
liters and this little decimal point
right over here makes it clear that
we're dealing with three significant
figures that we've rounded to the
nearest one when we got this when we
have this goal right over here we would
round to the nearest to the ones place i
guess so our goal is to have
half a liter of solution at a molarity
of 0.125
molar and then that is going to give us
the number of moles we need and if we
multiply this out this is going to be
zero
point let's see half of 12 is six and
then half of 50 is 25 0.0625
moles
moles of
solute
and in this case our solute is
sodium
sulfate and let's see if i got the
significant figures right i have 3 right
over here 1 2 three one two three so i
take the product i'd still have one two
three significant figures so this is our
goal we want to have this many moles of
solute so we just figure out how much of
our original solution do we need in
order to have that many moles of sodium
sulfate
so one way to think about it is there's
some mystery
volume of our original solution we need
and we know what its concentration is
it's a one molar
concentration that when i take this
product i'm going to get 0.0625
moles
of
sodium
sulfate
and the math here is pretty
straightforward we can divide both sides
by one molar and what are we going to
get and the units work out because we're
in moles where we have molar here and so
this is going to give us our answer in
liters you divide both sides by one
molar you're going to get that question
mark is
equal to
0.0625
liters of solution or another way to
think about it is this is equivalent to
62
point
milliliters of our original solution i
want to make sure i got all the
significant figures right had three over
there one two three one two three and so
yes right over here i can still have one
two three significant figures or
sometimes called significant digits and
so there we've answered our question
what i would do is i would take 62.5
62.5
milliliters of my original solution so
that's this over here
and then i would take my water and then
keep filling until i get to 500
milliliters and we're done at that point
i'm going to have a 0.125 molar of
sodium sulfate aqueous solution